[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى الملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه وكالمعتاد بابرز
عناوينها
[موسيقى]
هجوم روسي جديد على كييف والدفاع الروسيه
تعلن استهداف مراكز قياده ومخازن اسلحه
اوكرانيه بضربات دقيقه
اشتباكات في انحاء متفرقه من الخرطوم وسط
ترقب مع انتهاء هدنه الايام السبعه
ومحادثات في جده لتمديدها
الخارجيه الامريكيه للعربيه تكشف بحث جميع
الاليات المتاحه ومنها العقوبات لتطبيق
الهدنه بالسودان
هو الداخليه الايرانيه تعلن ان الحدود مع
افغانستان مفتوحه بعد الشبكات الحدوديه مع
طالبا امس
اهلا بكم استفاقت كييف اليوم على غاره
جويه روسيه جديده بعد سلسله ضربات الليليه
استهدفت مواقع عسكريه اوكرانيه قصف مكثف
يتزامن مع تحضير اوكرانيا للهجوم المضاد
على جبهات متعدده الاداره العسكريه في
كياب وقالت ان جميع الصواريخ الروسيه تم
اسقاطها ولم تصب هدفها واشار مراسل
العربيه ايضا الى ان الانذار الجوي لم يتم
في وقت مبكر وجاء متاخرا قبل ثلاث دقائق
فقط من الهجمات الروسيه واظهرت مقاطع
متداوله اعتراض الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه صواريخ روسيه في سماء كييف في
هجمات نادرا ما تحدث خلال النهار
الجيش الروسي ايضا اعلن استهداف مراكز
قياده ومعدات طيران ومخازن اسلحه وذخيره
اوكرانيه بضربات جويه على المطارات
الاوكرانيه خلال الليل واشار المتحدث باسم
الدفاع الروسيه الى ان الضربات كانت
باسلحه بعيده المدى وموجهه بدقه وحققت
بالفعل اهدافها
نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه الليله
الماضيه ضربه جماعيه باسلحه جويه بعيده
المدى موجهه بدقه ضد اهداف معاديه في
المطارات الاوكرانيه تم تحقيق هدف الضربه
الجويه وتدمير كل الاهداف نتيجه الضربه تم
تدمير مراكز القياده ومراكز الرادار وكذلك
معدات الطيران ومرافق تخزين اسلحه وذخائر
تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه
وينضم الينا من كييف مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه يوريساك مرحبا بك سيد يوري
العناوين العريضه تشير الى انكم تتعرضون
لهجوم عنيف والاعنف منذ خمسه عشر شهرا نحن
نتحدث عن هجوم بمصيرات قتاليه تهديد
صاروخي وجود حامله طائرات في البحر الاسود
انتم في موقف من الناحيه العسكريه كيف
تقيموه
مساء
عسكريا لان ما نتعامل معه ليس عن مجرد
عمليات عسكريه ما تعمل معه هو تصرفات
ارهابيه تشنها دولار ارهابيه وقائد اجرامي
في الكلام لانه يحاولوا ان يثبت لشعبه بكل
بس بان هذه الحرب بشكل منطقيا فبينما هم
غير قادرين على تحقيق النجاح العسكري على
ارض المعركه فباتوا يسعون لقتل اطفالنا
حاليا وبينما احدثكم الان هنالك صفارات
للغارات الجوافي كياب ومناطق اخرى من
اوكرانيا وهذا يعني بان المئات والالاف من
الاطفال الاوكرانيين يفرون من مدارسهم
للملاجئ فروسيا هذه الدوله الارهابيه
المثيره للشفقه تقاتل وتقتله الاطفال
الاوكرانيين
وسوف نهزمهم على ارض المعركه وانتقامنا
سيكون قويا جدا طيب المؤش
رات وان ما كان يتم الحديث عنه من هجوم
اوكرانيا مضاد لم يحدث حتى اللحظه وكان
روسيا باغتتكم
[موسيقى]
نحن نعيش في اجواء الارهاب هذه منذ فتره
طويله منذ اكثر من 14 شهرا الروس هؤلاء
الارهابيين اخطاوا الظن باعتقادهم انهم
سيحطمون ارادتنا ويرضموننا على
مفاوضات من نوع المال ولكن كلما يحصل يزيد
من غضبنا وعزيمتنا ومن خلال تلقي
المساعدات العسكريه من حلفائنا فنحن نقتل
الروس على ارض المعركه اكثر مئتين الف
جندي روسي قتلوا وسوف نقتل المزيد ما لم
يغادر اراضينا فامامهم اما خيارين
الاستسلام او الموطن اما فيما يخص
هجومنا ولم يحصل الان فهذا غير صحيح لان
الهجوم المضاده هو لا يتمثل بعمليه عسكريه
واحده في ساعه معينه ثم نراها على شاشه
تلفزيون هذه الهجمات المضاده هي سلسله من
العمليات الصغيره والكبيره والبعض منها
جاريه الصن وهي جاري منذ عده اسابيع طيب
الماضي يعتقد ان هناك خسائر كبيره يتكبدها
الجانب الاوكراني خلال الساعات الماضيه
نتيجه هذا القصف بالمصيرات القتاليه
التهديد الصاروخي الوصول الى قلب العاصمه
كييف في ساعات النهار وهو امر لم يكن يحدث
من قبل هل انتم مستعدون لهكذا تصعيد
ان هذا تصعيدا خطير ستتعامل معه عسكريا
بشكل مختلف
لا نبالي بما يظنه او يقوله بالنسبه لنا
وبالاقيه العالم المتحضر روسيا دوله
ارهابيه
وهنالك مذكره اعتقال رئيسهم فلا يهمنا ما
يقولونه يظنونه نحن نعرف ما سنفعله وسوف
نستلم ونستقبل ليس فقط طارت لابسه عشر بل
صواريخ بعيده المدى وسوف نهزم روسيا على
ارض المعركه
وسوف تكون هنالك محكمه جنائيه دوليه وسوف
نحاكمهم على جرائم الحرب هذه هذا ما سيحصل
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني يوريساك شكرا لك
وفي القرود اعلن حاكم المقاطعه في كلادا
كوفا تعرض مناطق متعدده من المقاطعه
لهجمات الاوكرانيه واشار الى ان منشاتين
صناعيتين تعرضت للقصف واصيب اربعه اشخاص
واضاف ان المقاطعه تعيش في حاله حرب
حقيقيه وان الضم كاركيف لروسيا سيكون حلا
للقصف المستمر على اراضي بالقرود
وينضم الينا من دونيسكا زميل رائد الاغبر
مراسل عربيه مرحبا بك رائد العمليات
العسكريه على الارض كيف تتم في هذه
اللحظات في ضوء هذا التصعيد العسكري ما
بين الجانبين الاوكراني والروسيه
[موسيقى]
المنطقه هنا في مقاطعه دانيت تشهد ايضا
تطورا كبيرا في المعارك في المناطق
الشماليه لكن دعينا نتحدث عن منطقه بلغراد
اولا التي باتت تشهد ضربات اوكرانيه بشكل
يومي اليوم كان هناك ضرب لاحدى البلدات
على اطراف المدينه عده ضربات صاروخيه
وبالمسيرات اسفرت عن اربعه اصابات قال
حاكم كييف كما اسلفت بان الضم مقاطعه
خارجف وهي في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
والمتاخمه لمدينه بلغراد ربما يخفف من هذا
الضغط العسكري او الاعتداء الاوكراني على
الاراضي الروسيه
له دلالات هل هي فكره العذب عن المواجهه
العسكريه
را هكذا التصريح
ربما يجدر القول بان العمليه العسكريه
مستمره وتشمل اراضي
واسعه وشاسعه ومساحات كبيره من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ذلك ما يجعل يعني التواجد
الروسي على الاراضي الروسيه في العمق
الروسي اقل بكثير من تواجد الجنود الروس
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه المقصود طبعا يعني
ميدان المعارك وربما ان روسيا لم تتوقع
هذا من الجانب الاوكراني ان تقصف اوكرانيا
الاراضي الروسيه ويعني تتجرا على الاعتداء
على العمق الروسي لكن بالنسبه للجانب
الاوكراني فهو لن يخسر شيء فهو يعتبر بان
يعني الجيش الروسي هو عدو ولن يحدث اكثر
من ما هو حاصل الان من تقدم للقوات
الروسيه او سيطره على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
المعارك بالفعل مستمر والمق
من السلطه في موسكو رشا يؤكدون بان هذا هو
الهجوم المضاد الذي وعدت به اوكرانيا وهو
مخالف لكل المعايير التي توقعها كانوا
يتوقعون تكون على غرار ما حدث في خرسون
وفي لمان هجمات مضاده بريه ودفع للقوات
الروسيه للانسحاب لكن لم يتوقعوا ان تكون
الضربات في العمق الروسي وعلى الاراضي
الروسيه خارج عن ميدان المعارك في منطقه
الدمباس وخرسون وزبره لماذا زالت المعارك
مستمره فلابد من الاشاره ايضا وبعجال رشا
بان منطقه
باخموت التي شهدت سيطره كامله لقوات فاغنر
ومن ثم تسليم للجيش الروسي ما زالت تشهد
معارك ضاريه في المحورين الجنوبي والشمالي
ليس في داخل المدينه لكن على اطراف
المدينه حيث بلده كليشيفكا وبلده خرومافا
تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه بهجوم مضاد على
بلده كليشيف كا وتقدم للقوات تستقر فيها
الاوضاع لصالح روسيا بعد هكذا تقصد
الزميلي رائد الاخبار
ونبقى معكم ومع ملفات الخامسه من العربيه
ولدينا
اردوغان يبدا ولايته الجديده بملفات
داخليه وخارجيه مثقله
نتابع معكم ملفات الخامسه من العربيه
ونذهب الى متابعه تطورات الملف السوداني
تنتهي اليوم هدنه وقت اطلاق النار قصير
المدى الموقعه في جده في العشيم من مايو
الحالي بين الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع
تواصل المحادثات غير المباشره التي تقودها
الوساطه السعوديه والامريكيه بين الطرفين
وقد شهدت اجزاء من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم سلسله الشبكات عنيفه استمرت حتى
فجر اليوم وقال سكان المحليون انهم سمعوا
دوي اشتباكات في مناطق جنوب وغرب ام درمان
احدى المدن الثلاث المتجاوره التي تشكل
معا ولايه الخرطوم كما اكد السكان حدوث
اشتباكات في مناطق عده بجنوب الخرطوم على
الضفه الاخرى لنهر النيل في وقت متاخر من
مساء الاحد
ومن جدات انضموا الينا مديره مكتب العربيه
في السودان الزميله لنا يعقوب مرحبا بك
لينا لينا ماذا عن الجهود لتمديد الهدنه
هل تم التوصل الى اتفاق من هذا النوع وهل
هناك امال لهدن طويله الامد دون اختراق
اهلا بك يا رشا ستستمر هذه الموحادثات ومن
المتوقع ان يصدر قرار من الوساطه مساء هذا
اليوم كلا الطرفين الجيش والدعم السريع
تحدثا في وقت سابق انهما مع تمديد هذه
الهدنه التي استمرت لمده اسبوع كان فيها
كثير من الخروقات طبعا من كلا الطرفين
ولكن كان هناك التزام ايضا كبير بحسب
الوساطه وبحسب المواطنين خاصه في العاصمه
الخرطوم وكذلك مدينتي بحري وام درمان
الاشتباكات كانت اقل بكثير من الاسابيع
الماضيه التي كانت فيها الحرب مشتعله بلا
شك ان الوساطه ستحاول
التركيز على النقاط التي كان فيها
عدم التزام من كلا الطرفين تحدثت عن نقاط
من جانب الجيش خاصه انه حسب الاتفاق
الموقع يجب ان لا يكون هناك تحليق
للطائرات او قصف او اي طيران مسير كذلك من
جانب الدعم السريع يجب
اخلاء هذه المستشفيات التي تم احتلالها في
وقت سابق وكذلك المساكن والبيوت لذلك
الوساطه تحدثت عن استمرار لعمليات نهب
وسهل من قبل قوات الدعم السريع هذه النقاط
ستناقش اليوم ستكون هناك
فاعليه اكثر لتفعيل اليه الرقابه ولبحث
سبل جديده هي ليست جوله جديده كما ذكرنا
في هذا اليوم ولكنها استمرار المحادثه
والدعم السريع بصوره غير مباشره وحتى هذه
اللحظه
ذكرتي نقطه مهمه وهي فكره اليه المراقبه
الجميع يتحدث عن مدى فاعليه هذه الاليه
وهل هي موجوده بالفعل وفقا لاعلان جده
لانه هناك خروقات حدثت على مدى الايام
الماضيه كما كنت تذكرين وكل طرف يحمل
الطرف الاخر مسؤوليه الخرق هل هذه الاليه
ستعلن للراي العام ما حقيقه ما حدث هل
ستكون هناك توجيهات منها للاطراف التي لا
تلتزم بالهدنه
لاول مره تصدر بيان تتحدث فيه عن اختراقات
لكل جانب في الاوقات السابقه كانت تجمع
الطرفين لذلك هذا التحديد الذي قامت به
الوساطه بالنسبه لكثير من المواطنين هو
مطمئن من ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى هم يتحدثون
عن هناك كثير من الاعمال التي جاءت لاحقا
على سبيل المثال في حريه الصحافه كان هناك
اعتقال من قبل الجيش السوداني لصحفي صحيح
انه تم التحري معه واطلاق سراحه لاحقا
هناك اعتقال لطبيب على الجانب الاخر الدعم
السريع كان يعتدي على منازل صحفيين
واستمرت عمليات النهب والسلب لهذه المنازل
وهذه المناطق لذلك هناك الان شهادات تروى
بصوره واضحه من قبل شخصيات قد تكون معروفه
حتى بالنسبه للوساطه هذا الامر بحسب مصادر
مؤكده سيتم بحثه وسيتم النقاش حوله في
مساء هذا اليوم من المتوقع بحسب المصادر
ايضا ان
تمديد هذه الهدنه لا احد يعلم هل لاسبوع
اخر هل لايام اقل هل لاسبوعين ولكن هناك
جديه لتجديد هذه الهدنه مره اخرى من قبل
كلا الطرفين ربما يتم في هذا اليوم التحدث
عن هذه الاختراقات ووضع ايضا اليه تفعيل
جديده لعدم تكرار مثل هذه الامور في
الاوقات القادمه الزميله لنا يعقوب مديره
مكتب العربيه في السودان متحدثه الينا من
جده وفقا لمصادر سيتم العمل على تجديد
الهدنه الليله
في دارفور افاد الناطق العسكري لحركه جيش
تحرير السودان الرائد احمد حسين مصطفى
بوجود جماعات مسلحه نشطت في ولايه دارفور
تعمل على نهب وترويع المواطنين واستهداف
الممتلكات العامه والمؤسسات الخدميه مشيرا
الى ان هذه المجموعات مجهوله الهويه وقد
درجت على سرقه السيارات والقوافل التجاريه
هذا وتقوم حركه جيش تحرير السودان
بالتنسيق لتامين ولايه دارفور مشدده على
ان حمايه المواطن وممتلكاته هي اولويه
قصوى للحركه وحكومه الاقليم وداعيه في
الوقت كذلك جميع الاطراف للعمل من اجل
انهاء الحرب والعوده الى منصه الحوار
الاستئناف العمليه السياسيه بمشاركه اكبر
هذا واضحى ظهور السلاح باقليم دارفور بعد
القتال بين الجيش والدعم السريع مظهرا
شبيه بانه مظهر عادي للغايه على الرغم من
منعه في السابق يتخوف سكان الاقليم من
الدعوات المتكرره للتسلح من جهات نافذه
بان يتم تفاقم من حاله السيوله الامنيه
الحاليه
يتجول سليمان حسب الكريم بسلاحه داخل سوق
الضعين غربيه السودان في مشهد اصبح مالوفا
في مدن اقليم دارفور فمنذ اندلاع القتال
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في منتصف ابريل
الماضي عاد السلاح مره اخرى الى الزهور
بكثره في ايدي المواطنين بالاحياء
والاسواق حجتهم في ذلك حمايه انفسهم من
النهب والسلب
والله لحمايه نفسي بس وانا زلت تاجر وقاعد
في الخلا وشايل السلاح من النهب لعدم حفظ
الامن لانه ما في اسي دوله بتحمانا من
النهب والسلب عشان كذا انا شايل السلاح
حمايه نفسي وعشره دارفور في السنوات
السابقه صراعات عديده متواصله استخدم فيها
السلاح بشكل سافر مما جعل بعض القيادات
الاهليه تتخوف من تكرار ذات الخلافات
القديمه التي عاشها الاقليم بسبب السلاح
والسيوله الامنيه لذلك نحن نقول هذه
الخطوه خطوه غير موفقه ونحن نطالب المجتمع
الدولي والاخوه الوسطاء السعوديين
والمتحده ان يقفوا على هذه الحاله لان هذه
الازمه ستصبح ازمه يمكن يكون تضييق على
السودانيين فيما ينادي بعض المواطنين
بالمضي قدما في عمليات جمع السلاح بدلا من
تقنين انتشاره خوفا من الانزلاق الى الحرب
الاهليه بدرفور الى ان بعض المناطق ما
زالت ساخنه نحن نرفض جمله وتفصيلا لان
الاستنفار السلاح عند المواطن ذات نجمع
نحن الان نحن مع جهه وتجمع السلاح جمع
السلاح ومحاربه الظواهر السالمه نحن الان
ما دارين ينسى
الان محاربينها تماما وما دايرين اي خلل
وتقول جهات مختصه انه رغم الحملات
المتكرره فلا يزال السلاح بكافه انواعه
بحوزه سكان دارفور انقسام للمجتمع بدار 4
بين مؤيدين ورافض لفكره التسليح بغرض
الحمايه وبين مجموعه الرفض وتاييد قاسم
مشترك وحمايه الارواح والممتلكات وتعزيز
الامن والسلام
صالح ابو علامه لقناته العربيه والحدث
اقليم دارفور غربيه السودان
وينضموا الينا من اقليم دارفور الصحفيه
صالح ابو علامه مرحبا بك صالح صالح نريد
ان نتعرف على بعض المعلومات هذا التسلح او
موجه التسلح الموجوده الان في اقليم
دارفور هل هي لدى اشخاص عاديين لحمايه
انفسهم ام انه يمكن ان يسمى بتصلح قبلي
هناك قبائل معينه بدات تحمل السلاح في وجه
قبائل اخرى
مرحبا رشا هو السلاح في دارفور منتشر منذ
فتره ليست بالقصيره في السنوات السابقه
تمت عمليات تسليح كبيره جدا
يعني المجموعات السكانيه هنا في اقليم
دارفور بحجه التجنيد بحجه دخول في بعض
قوات
التي تم انشاؤها من قبل الدوله في السابق
هذا سلاح يعني هنالك بعض القرارات
الرئاسيه التي اتخذت في شانه وتمت عمليات
جمع لهذا السلاح ولكن هذه العمليات لم
تجمع كل السلاح المنتشر في اقليم دافور
حتى هذه اللحظه ما ان تقوم مشكله او يقوم
صراع ما حتى ياتي السلاح ويظهر الى العالم
بشكل كبير جدا قبائل معينه لنصر الطرف
معين في هذه الحرب ام انه بشكل عشوائي ما
بين المواطنين العاديين او ما بين سكان
العاديين
نعم هو سلاح ما بين المواطنين لكن يعني
حتى هؤلاء المواطنين هم ينتمون الى قبائل
ولديهم حواضر اجتماعيه كبيره في اقليم
دارفور هنا في غرب السودان هذه المجموعات
هي من تكون القبائل وهي من تكون ايضا
المجتمع هنا في اقليم دارفور نجد بان يعني
قطاع واسع منهم مسلح لشتى انواع الاسلحه
الثقيله والخفيفه هذه الحرب ايضا عندما
جاءت زادت من حده التسلح نسبه لعمليات
الكبيره
او مقترنه بمواجهات واشتباكات ام انها فقط
حمل للسلاح تحسبا لوقوع اي هجوم في اي وقت
نعم هي هي هي تحسبا
للاشتباكات تحسبا للتفلت لكن تدخل احيانا
في عمليات قراع قبلي يعني دائما من يسلح
نفسه ويحمل السلاح اما قتل من اجل سلاحه
او هو قتله بالسلاح الذي يحمله يدخل عدد
كبير من الافراد في عمليات صراع مع يعني
مجموعات نهب هذا النهب يتحول مباشره الى
عمليات حرب قبليه بين المجموعات السكانيه
كما ان البعض يستخدم هذا السلاح في تصفيه
مرارات قديمه في تصفيه مشكلات شخصيه ايضا
تطور الى صراع قبلي باقليم دارفور اليوم
عمليات النهب التي تجري الان في الطرقات
الرابطه بين المدن ما هي الا انتشار لهذا
السلاح في ايدي المواطنين لذلك لا يمكن
ضبط هذا السلاح ابدا لا يمكن ابدا ان نقول
ان سلاح هذا يمكن ان يستخدم فقط في حمايه
الانفس طالما ان سلاح موجود وتجاره السلاح
موجوده
تدخل يعني هذه العمليه في عمليه كارفور
تاريخ طويل في هذا الامر الصحفي صلاح ابو
علامه من اقليم دارفور شكرا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات
وفي شان المتصل بتطوراتي في السودان كشف
تقرير منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه في الامم
المتحده عن تفاقم ازمه الامن الغذائي في
اثنتين وعشرين دوله وذلك بسبب النزاعات
والظروف المناخيه والاضطرابات الاقتصاديه
التي تواجهها بعض الدول الناميه حسب
التقرير فان افغانستان واليمن ونيجيريا
والصومال وجنوب السودان لا تزال الاكثر
ضعفا بالاضافه الى بوركينا فاسو وهييتي
ومالي والسودان اضاف تقرير ايضا ان الوضع
في السودان قد يؤدي الى عواقب سلبيه في
الدول المجاوره والى تعطل طرق الشحن
التجاريه والانسانيه الى الموانئ بسبب
انعدام الامن بالطبع وهو ما يهدد تدفقات
المساعدات الانسانيه وجهود الاغاثه
الاقليميه
والى تركيا بدا رئيس تركيا رجب طيب
اردوغان اليوم مهمه رئاسيه تركيه وعلى
جدول اعماله مهمات صعبه داخليا وخارجيا
وقد تبينت اراء الاتراك بشان نتيجه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره نتابع
الحمد لله تم انتخابه انها نتيجه جيده لان
طيب اردوغان زعيم جيد ويعرف ما يريده
الشعب اذا كان الناس يصوتون له لمده 20
عاما فلابد انه قائد ناجح طيب اردوغان هو
الافضل وانا ادعمه باي شكل من الاشكال
اصبح لدينا شباب مستاء بشكل حقيقي انظر
الى الناس من حولي الذين كانوا يدعمون
المعارضه جميعهم مستاءون لقد نسينا
الربيعه في هذا البلد ليس هناك ما تفعله
اعتقد انها كانت انتخابات غير عادله لان
البلاد في وضع سيء لقد كان لدينا مرشح
مختلف في قلوبنا شخص يمكنه حقا قياده هذا
البلد لكن الامر لم ينجح لنامل الافضل
السؤال الذي يواجه تركيا الان هو ما الذي
سيفعله زعيم التركي بعد ذلك صحيفه بروتو
الامريكيه القت الضوء على اراء انصار
اردوغان كما منتقدي فيما يخص النهج الذي
سيتبعه في السياسه الداخليه والخارجيه
منتقدوا اردوغان يقولون ان فوزه سيعكسوا
سيطرته على موارد الدوله بشكل اكثر
وسيواصل سيطرته ايضا على معظم وسائل
الاعلام بالاضافه الى سجن شخصيات بارزه في
المعارضه والمجتمع المدني كما ان خمس
سنوات اخرى من حكم اردوغان في السلطه قد
توجه ضربه مدمره للديمقراطيه التركيه وهذا
الخوف الذي اعرضت عنه العديد من جماعات
المعارضه بينما يرد انصار اردوغان بان
التصويت يعكس تقدير الاتراك لسنوات
اردوغان العشرين في منصبه اولا كرئيس
للوزراء ومن ثم كرئيس للبلاد يقول انصار
اردوغان ان البلاد اقوى بكثير مما كانت
عليه قبل 20 عاما بسبب النمو الاقتصادي
وتحسين البناء التحتيه بالاضافه الى دور
تركي اكثر نشاطا في شؤون العالميه كما ان
اردوغان لا يخشى اتخاذ خط مستقل عن الغرب
وفقا لمؤيدي على الرغم من كون تركيا عضو
في حلف الناتو
ومن انقره ينضم الينا الزميل زيدان زنكروا
مراسل العربيه وتغطيته وفريق العربيه
مستمره حتى بعد اعلان النتائج زيدان هناك
فرحه في اوساط حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم في تركيا وهناك خيبه امل لدى
المعارضه كيف انعكس ذلك على الشارع التركي
نعم رشا تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع المشاهدين
قبل ان اجيب عن هذا السؤال ساسرد بعض
الاخبار السريعه واخر تطورات لهذا اليوم
وما ستحمله الايام القادمه طبعا ساذكر
بنتيجه انقره هنا نحن حيث نتواجد في
العاصمه التركيه
حاز الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على
48.77% بينما حاز منافسه كمالك الجدار
اوغلو على
51.23% نسبه المشاركه في انقره انخفضت من
90.8% في الجوله الاولى الى
88% في الجوله الثانيه طبعا بحسب ما تم
اعلانه اليوم من الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
سيتم الاعلان بشكل رسمي عن النتائج
النهائيه للانتخابات البرلمانيه والرئاسيه
في يوم في الاول من يونيو القادم اي بعد
يومين على ان يجتمع البرلمان المنتخب بعد
ثلاثه ايام من اعلان النتائج الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه لاتمام عمليات اداء اليمين
الدستوريه ومن ثم انتخاب رئيس للبرلمان اي
ان الاجتماع الاول للبرلمان سيكون في
الرابع من يونيو القادم بالعوده طبعا الى
سؤالك او قبل ان اعود ايضا الى السؤال
هناك تصريحات كانت من ابراهيم كلن المتحدث
باسم الرئاسه التركيه اليوم قال ان الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان سيجري اليوم
اتصالا هاتفيا مع نظيره الامريكي جو بايدن
لبحث عده قضايا طبعا كان هنا اردوغان يوم
امس بفوزه بالانتخابات طبعا الشارع التركي
لا شك انصار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اقاموا الاحتفالات حتى ساعات
الصباح الباكر هنا في العاصمه التركيه
انقره كما في اسطنبول وعديد المدن التركيه
نعم لا شك هي المهم لديهم النتيجه وليس
موضوع المدن في النهايه الرئيس اردوغان
فاز برئاسه تركيا بغض النظر عن المدن التي
فاز بها هكذا يقولون طبعا كنا نسال جميع
السكان هنا لماذا تغير المزاج في انقره او
حتى في اسطنبول لكن كان الجواب بان المهم
النتيجه النهائيه في عموم تركيا لا يهم ان
كانت اسطنبول او انقر لا شك هي دفع معنويه
كبيره ان كانت المدن الكبرى صوتت للرئيس
التركي لكن المهم النتيجه الكبيره والتقدم
المريح الذي
حققه الرئيس رجب حسن
يعود الى مساله الشارع لان النت
ائج
بشكل انتصار بطعم الهزيمه وهزيمه بطعم
النصر يعني المعارضه انتصرت بشكل كبير في
عدد من المدن الرئيسيه كيف كان تفاعل
الشارع مع هذا الامر هل كان هناك نوع من
الصدمه لدى السكان في انقره مثلا باعتبار
انهم صوتوا للمعارضه
نعم الفوارق في انقره واسطنبول كانت بسيطه
لنتحدث عن اثنين في المئه او ثلاثه في
المئه على ابعد تقدير يعني لكن لا شك كما
ذكرت الصدمه الكبرى لدى انصار المعارضه
الذين علقوا امال كبيره على
سواء في البرلمان او حتى في الرئاسه وكانت
الخساره في البرلمان والرئاسه بالتالي
الصدمه الكبيره لا شك ان هناك كانت يعني
الكثير كانوا يعتبرون ان هذه الفرصه
تاريخيه للمعارضه التركيه لكن لم تنجح في
استغلال هذه الفرصه كون البلاد كانت تعيش
في وقع على وقع ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره او
التضخم غير مسبوق هو الاول ووصل الى اعلى
مستوياته منذ قدوم حزب العداله والتنميه
ايضا ما فاقم الامور هو الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب الولايات الجنوبيه او 11
ولايه جنوبيه لكن في العموم تلك الولايات
او معظم الولايات التي ضربها زلزال صوتت
لاردوغان بالتالي كان هناك صدمه بين اوساط
المعارضه خصوصا سهام الانتقادات توجه نحوك
كمالك الجدار اوغلو لانه اصر على الترشح
رغم كل استطلاعات الراي التي سبقت اختياره
كمرشح لتحالف الطاوله السداسيه التي كانت
لا تعطيه افضليه في التنافس مع اردوغان
انما كانت تعطي افضليه لرئيس بلديه
اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو ورئيس بلديه
انقره منصور وبالتالي من المنتظر او من
المتوقع ان يكون هناك تداعيات سياسيه او
تداعيات داخل معسكر المعارضه ونتحدث
تحديدا عن حزب الشعب الجمهوري اكبر احزاب
المعارضه ورئيس هذا الحزب كمالك
شكرا لك زيدان على كل هذه المعلومات
والى مجموعه من الاخبار قال وزير الداخليه
الايرانيه احمد وحيدي ان الحدود مع
افغانستان مفتوحه ولا توجد مشكله في حركه
العبور اضاف وحيد الوكاله تسنيم الايرانيه
للانباء انا للشبكات الحدوديه بين ايران
وافغانستان كانت محدوده وتم حلها مجددا
على ان الاوضاع على الحدود مع افغانستان
الان هادئه
تاتي هذه التصريحات بعد الصدمات الحدوديه
بين طالبان وايران قياديه في حركه طالبان
كان ذكر امس بان عناصر الحركه ستحتل ايران
خلال 24 ساعه محذرا طهران من اختبار قوه
طالبان على حد قوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وعنضم الينا من كابول مراسل العربيه
عبدالله نادر مرحبا بك عبد الله كيف تبدو
الامور على الحدود وهل هي هادئه بالفعل
وماذا عن لغه التصعيد الاعلاميه من قبل
حركه طالبان
نعم فقد عاد الهدوء الى الحدود الافغانيه
والايرانيه بعد نزاع مسلح عنيف بين
الطرفين ما ادى الى مقتل جنديين من الحرس
الحدودي الايراني ومقتل جندي من القوات
الامنيه في طالبان معبر او جسر الحرير
المعبر الوحيد في هذه المقاطعه مقاطعه
النمروز بين الحدود الافغانيه والحدود
الايرانيه
قد تم فتحه اليوم بعد اغلاق الدم يوما
كاملا منذ امس وهذا المعبر الان مفتوح
لنقل
البضائع وكذلك
للمسافرين والعابرين من هذا المعبر
هناك تواصلات بين الطرفين وبين البلدين
على مستوى الوزراء
واللغه التصعيد ما زالت موجوده
وكذلك
القوات المحتشده بين الحدود الافغانيه
الايرانيه ما زالت متواجده في الحدود
العلاقه بينهما الى هذا المستوى من
المواجهه المباشره لماذا
العلاقات بين افغانستان وايران متوتره منذ
قديم وخاصه في عهد طالبان الاول وكذلك في
عهد طالبان الحالي فقد كانت هناك حروب بين
طالبان في اوائل او في التسعينات من القرن
الماضي وكارت هناك دبلوماسيون ايرانيون قد
قتلوا بعدما سيطر طالبان على مدينه مزار
شريف وكانت حروب بين الطالبان في عهد
الاول وبعد السيطره طالبان كذلك كانت هناك
مناوشات وحروب
واشتباكات على هذه الحدود الافغانيه
الايرانيه وفي الاونه الاخيره
حدثت هناك توترات الدبلوماسيه السياسيه
جراء المياه الافغانيه التي تتدفق الى
الاراضي الايرانيه
فبنت الحكومه او النظام السابق الرئيس
اشرف غني سدودا على هذه المياه الافغانيه
التي تنبع من الجبال في افغانستان وا يران
تطالب بحقها من هذه المياه
حسب
الاتفاقيه المبرمه عام
افغانستان وطالبان لا تنكر هذه المعاهده
ولكنها تقول ان الجفاف والقحطه
يؤدي الى هذه المواجهات ولكن الامور على
الحدود الافغانيه الايرانيه هدات الان
وفقا للمراسل العربيه عبد الله نادر انك
عبد الله
[موسيقى]
تم نشر الشرطه وقوات حفظ السلام في شمال
كوسوفو ذات الاغلبيه الصربيه وسط تصاعد
التوتر بين السلطات والصرب جاء ذلك في
اعقاب حادث وقع في وقت سابق الجمعه عندما
حاول الصب الذين يشكلون الاغلبيه في شمال
كوسوفا منع المسؤولين الالبان المنتخبين
حديثا من دخول المباني البلديه وقطع الصرب
الانتخابات المحليه التي جرت الشهر الماضي
ولم يتم انتخاب سوى ممثلي العرق الالباني
او غيرهم من ممثل الاقليات الاصغر في
مناصب مجالس البلديه وادارتها
ونبقى معكم ومع ملفات الخامسه ولدينا بعد
هذا الفاصل
تساقط للبرد في الاردن يتسبب بوفاه شاب
غرقا في العقبه وخسائر ماديه
اهلا بكم من جديد رائد الفضاء السعوديان
ريان برناوي وعلي القرني في رحله فضائيه
تاريخيه شغلت اذهان متابعيهم كيف تاقلم
خارج القرى الارضيه وكيف يقضيان يومهما في
المحطه الفضائيه الدوليه الزميله روان
حمزه تجيب عن تلك التساؤلات في تقرير
التالي
بعد وصول رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علي
القرني وريانه برناوي لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه بدات مهمتهما العلميه ودارت في
اذهان متابعي الحدث التاريخي اسئله عديده
فقمنا نحن في قناه العربيه بالبحث عن
الاجابات التاليه علي وريان يحملان على
عاتقهما اربع عشره تجربه علميه بمعدل
تجربتين يوميا في بيئه خاصه منها تجارب
بعينات جاهزه مثل اي نوع من انواع
الالتهابات وهناك تجارب تتطرق لصحه
الانسان في الفضاء كالتاقلم مع البيئه او
قياس العلامات الحيويه مثل قياس قطري عصب
العين واخرى مثل عمليات الاستمطار وقياس
تاثيرها وانعكاساتها البيئيه اسئله اخرى
شغلتكم وشغلنا البحث عن اجابتها كيف يتغذى
رائد الفضاء السعوديان خارج الكره الارضيه
مشاهدينا كمال سكان الارض حميات غذائيه
محدده لزوار الفضاء ايضا حميه خاصه مكونه
من ثلاث وجبات يوميا محضره باشتراطات ناسا
كيف ينام رواد الفضاء مع انعدام الجاذبيه
واختلاف التوقيت الزمني والبيئه يبدا يوم
رواد الفضاء الساعه الثامنه صباحا وحتى
الساعه السادسه مساء تتخلله اوقات للانشطه
بعدها يحين وقت الراحه داخل حقيبه نوم
خاصه مثبته ماذا عن التواصل مع سكان الارض
الاهل والاصدقاء نعم مسموح لرواد الفضاء
بالتواصل مع من يريدون لكن عبر الاتصال
الصوتي فقط اما المرئي فيخصص للفريق الطبي
واخيرا
نطمئن مشاهدينا بان جميع من على محطه
الفضاء مدربون على الاسعافات الاوليه
للتعامل مع اي حالات طارئه لا قدر الله
خبر غير صار من ابل خصوصا الذين يخزنون
صورهم على ماي فوتوستريم ابل اعلنت ايقاف
امكانيه تخزين المستخدمين للصور على متن
الخدمه في السادس والعشرين من يونيو على
ان يتم ايقاف الخدمه المجانيه لحفظ الصور
بشكل نهائي في السادس والعشرين من يوليو
القادم دعت ابل المستخدمين الى ضروره
الاعتماد على خدمه تخزين الصور في اي
كلاود فوتوز كبديلا لخدمتها في ماي
فوتوسترين كما ان جميع الصور التي يحتفظ
او يحتفظ بها مستخدمه مايفوتوسيرين سيتم
مزامنتها مع خدمه ايكلاود وستظل متاحه
لمده شهر من تاريخ السادس والعشرين من
يوليو بحيث يتمكن المستخدم خلال تلك
الفتره من نقل صوره المحفوظه
تسببت حاله عدم الاستقرار الجوي في الاردن
بوفاه شاب غرقا من سيول هادره بمحافظه
العقبه جنوب البلاد كما تضررت مئه
المركبات جراء تساقط حبه البرد
[تصفيق]
نهايه الخامسه من العربيه ولكن خدمتنا
الاخباريه مستمره على صفحاتنا وعلى موقع
العربيه تابعونا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات